we are going to go to the phones a day
early this week at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 52
account for a professional development
day on Friday there will be no Friday
show this week so we're taking calls a
day early let's go to our first caller
from the 972 area code caller what's
your name and where are you calling from
hi David my name is Michael I'm calling
from Jerusalem Israel great what's on
your mind today ok I wanted to ask you
about you familiar with the incident
with Bret Weinstein and evergreen
college no I'm not ok so just quickly
there's a professor in a liberal arts
college in evergreen college in Seattle
Arkin Seattle area and there was an
incident there where he wrote an email
protesting this day of absence that was
going on in the campus where
traditionally people of color used to be
just black people then it was expanded
to people of color would take a day
every year to spend off of campus kind
of highlighting their their value and
this year they reversed it so that the
the way it was going to be the way it
was going to be held was that white
people were basically encouraged not to
come to campus for one day and he wrote
an email and he wrote an email on this
large chain which included his staff and
students very well well thought out
well-written email saying that he felt
uncomfortable with this with this idea
and that he was against it and he he was
not planning on on he was planning on
coming to campus that day and he was
subsequently later that they shouted
down by a large group of students and
there's been calls for him to be to be
fired and it's caused quite a stir I
don't know I guess you're not aware of
this up I'm not aware of it but we've
covered similar stories and you know
what I find that this entire type of
thing really disappointing because the
now the controversy you've described and
again I'm going by what you've told me
the controversy you've described is
number one taking away from whatever
were the original intentions
this day as originally conceived and I'm
sure that no one is well served by that
if they're trying to shine a light on
particular issues that that are notable
or observable in society and also you
know on another level
I don't know this professor but I'm
guessing that he's probably Jewish right
and last name is Weinstein yeah he
actually is and he when he's disgusted
he highlights that that fact kind of
makes him if he says it makes him
uncomfortable the second that he's not
allowed to go somewhere it beats
somewhere well I wasn't thinking along
those lines Michael I was thinking I
wasn't thinking along those lines I was
thinking along the lines of this idea
now that because Eastern European Jews
look white and admittedly for the most
part pass as white in Western society
and have the benefits of white privilege
to whatever extent you believe that
non-jewish Europeans have it at European
Jews would also have it
Jews are part of one of the most
discriminated groups of people in the
history of mankind since discrimination
started going back thousands and
thousands of years in the idea that he
now is someone who is being told this is
about raising awareness about groups
that are historically marginalized and
you're not allowed to be here or you
shouldn't be here I guess is what he's
been told it just makes no sense to me
whatsoever right did you mind if I ask a
question I actually want to ask you a
question about it go ahead real quick
yeah okay real quick so in general as a
progressive myself I feel that usually
regressives all to talk about regressive
less than safe spaces and colleges it's
usually kind of it distracts from the
larger issues and I've tended to feel
that it's kind of not as big as an issue
as some people would like to make it to
be but I couldn't help but feel this
time and together with other recent
incidents I mean there's a famous
incident yell with Erika Christakis and
Berkeley protests so I'm starting to
feel that maybe this is a larger trend
and I wanted to get your thoughts if you
think this is something that could
actually be pervasive so as to really
kind of creep into the general you know
dialog of the lesser progressives in the
way that they got talked about seeing
similar to other movements that have
started on campus like yeah rights
movement that have been successful and
positive but this one is red so I would
listen I I don't want to overstate how
much of a problem this is we've got a
piece coming up on political correctness
and we're going to address that I think
it is an issue but that it is also
largely overblown by some people that
doesn't mean it's not an issue and we're
going to we're going to outline that in
detail on an upcoming long-form piece so
I won't preempt that now Michael thanks
for the call from Jerusalem much
appreciated hope to hear from you again